こんにちはこちらスティーブです
今日はリンクのメンバーに対するビデオ
です
最近人気でもう一つの変化
改善だと思いますけども変化があったこれ
からはですね全てのメンバーが
なり得る
その変化に対してはいくつかの意見が出て
ますある人はその心配してますこういう風
にすればどうやってその
品質を確認できますかと
それについてちょっとお話ししたんです
今現在でもうちのチーターが
非常に人気のある歌非常にポピュラー非常
にその資格がある
リングスティック博士とかそういうような
人でもですね時々
その
急にその
ディスカッションを取り消したりするよう
なことも最近あったわけですよだから人の
資格人のその1次の人気にもかかわらず
こういう問題が起こりうる
だからですね
我々が
その非常に限定された人にしかトヨタの
資格を与えないあるいは誰でも下院の誰で
も
絨毯になる売るということに関してはです
ねその取り消しが起こるか起こらないかと
いうことに対してはそう影響はないと思い
ます
我々がそのポイント制度がありますだから
その取り消したら
もちろんトヨタがポイントももらわないし
それから生徒もポイズも払わないだから
その他それがうちのそのライブもかその他
との
差がある
それによってできるだけやはりポイントを
取るために渋滞がその
約束した時間にですね来るようになると
思います
もし
ある特定のデータがそのよくその
約束した時間ですね来なかったりとか
取り消しするようなことがあったらその人
は資格取りますそういうことがあった時に
我々会員の中でですねの間でその話をすれ
ばあるいは直接私なりマークに連絡すれば
我々は
適当な
措置はとりますでトヨタそのものはですね
これが
リンクでは党の言語がある英語だけじゃ
なくて日本語もスペイン語フランス語
ロシア語その他すべてに関してはですね
全ての人を絨毯に
特定の資格を要求してもですねまずその
良い休暇その品質の保証人もなりませんし
それからそれも非常に難しいわけですねと
いうのはそれぞれの人には好き嫌いがあり
ます私の場合はロシア語を勉強してます
4つの
絨毯を持ってますみんなそれぞれ味が違い
ますある人は非常に話が面白いけれども
ディスカッションレポートがちょっと短い
とかもう一人の人が話がそれほど
活発じゃないけれども非常に徹底した
ディスカッションレポートを作りましただ
からそれぞれみんな良さあるいは
弱点があるわけですよねそしてその
作文もですねの転職も私が9と選ぶわけ
ですよで私も3つぐらいの
違った絨毯を使ってますで場合によって
今度新しいトヨタが現れたらですねまあ私
もこの絨毯も使ってみると思いますで
僕にとってはですねその
清田というのは基本的にはその言葉という
のはそれは誰か教えるようなもんじゃなく
てそれは自分から勉強しなくちゃならない
でもしその中でですねある一人の
絨毯が思うほどあるいは
期待したほど
良くなかったとかいうのはねそれ大きな
影響はないですかえってうちの場合は洗濯
を広げることによってですねいろんな人に
話しできていろんな
違ったタイプのトヨタと関係を作ることが
できるその中で特に好きな人とはよくそれ
その人の
ディスカッションに参加したり
そんなには好きじゃないけどもこのテーマ
に関してはこの人が一番いいんだとかこう
いうような作文の場合はこの人がいいとか
いろんな
選択を増やしていけば結果的にはその皆
さんメンバーの言葉の勉強にとってはです
ねそれはいいことだと思います
で
将来もそういう
トヨタが評価制評価制といって
コンピューターが悪いというその
単なるそのなんですか
自分の名前も出さずにこの人が悪いという
制度は良くないだから
この人は特に良いという
favoritedは多分
導入すると思いますじゃないとどこか誰か
の人にはですね昨日会わなかったためこの
人が悪いとその悪いという判断が出たら
この人このトヨタがその後は難しいとそう
じゃなくてね西部率制度はこれから導入は
すると思うんですけれどもいずれ私がいく
つかの言葉日本語も含めてブラジル語
イタリア語フランス語ロシア語ドイツ語
ですねうちのチーターと話をした中でです
ね悪いのが一つもなかっただけどもその他
その中では
これに関してはこの人がいいこれに関して
はあの人はいいということはあるでその
信頼性っていうかその
急にそのディスカッションを取り消したり
するようなことはこれは誰とでもあり得る
ことですどんな資格があってもですねそれ
あり得ることそれも我々できるだけ避け
たいしだからポイント制度を
取り入れてます
取り消したらポンチはもらえないとだけど
もそれはいろんな人にはいろんな事情が
ある非常に人気のある人が
急に何か個人的な何か起こったためにその
連発して取り消したりするようなことは
あるそれはその
絨毯の近くとか今度我々が
うちのカイン誰でも中太になりうるという
こととは直接僕は関係ないと思いますと
同時にうちのフォーラムで英語でも日本語
でも
雇用住宅が欲しいとかこういうその
専門分野の
詳しい人お話とお話ししたいと誰か推薦し
てくださいとかあの人に話ししましたけど
もう一つ良くなかったということもそれも
言っていいわけですよそれは自分の名前
出して言えばいい私はスチームです私は
この人は良くないと思うとそれはいいと
ただあのただただ
敵だけ出して自分の名前出さないで言うの
がそれは私はあまり賛成しませんだから
我々はこの
リンクのコミュニティでお互いにそして
その
コミュニティのメンバー同士尊敬しながら
私がスペイン語ならスペイン語を探して
スペイン語の
母国語として
いるメンバーを探してどうですか少し僕の
9点になってくれませんかと私もやったら
もう英語でも同じことをやってあげますよ
とただそのリンク制度でちゃんときちんと
ね時間を決めてスケジュールうちの
スケジュール制度を使ってねそして
ディスカッションレポートも送ったりね
書いたり送ったりするような形でそれを
どんどん増やしていきたいとだから結果は
ですねより豊富な選択より
豊富な効果的な言葉の勉強にはなると思い
ますまあまたフォーラムでこの話も続き
ましょう皆さんいろいろその辺その新しい
変更ね
導入した際にですねいくつかのバーグが
あってすいませんでしたこれもどんどん
解決してそれからもっと活発なね
楽しいその言葉の勉強のコミュニティは
なるように
努力してますどうもありがとう